Here's a scientific mystery for you.
Does hot water freeze faster than cold water?
The answer is...
We don't know.
You're probably thinking, how can we not know?
I mean, we've all got water.
Most of us have a freezer.
This seems like a pretty simple experiment.
Well you're right, it is, it also isn't.
The experiment has been performed...
...by brilliant people all over the world.
And in those experiments,...
...sometimes hot water freezes faster than cold water.
And sometimes it doesn't.
And either way, the results of the experiment are not reproducible.
The observation that hot water will freeze faster...
...than cold water is called the Mpemba Effect.
It's named after Erasto Mpemba,...
...who noticed the effect in 1963...
...when he was just thirteen years old...
...and making ice cream with his classmates.
He noticed that the ice cream mixture...
...made with hot milk froze faster...
...than the mixture made with cold milk.
However, he wasn’t the first person to make this claim.
Aristotle said the same thing in the year 4 BCE.
Just, you know, not about ice cream.
Rene Descartes and Francis Bacon also believed...
...that hot water froze faster than cold water.
But scientists aren't convinced...
...that the Mpemba Effect is actually a thing.